You know what's nice?
I went backstage to say hi before the show and your mom was there.
You introduced me and I always think it's nice...
...when people bring their family along with them to showbiz occasions or events.
I think it's kind of cool.
Yeah, it's kind of fun.
Who did you bring?
You were nominated for a Golden Globe and you brought,...
...who did you bring?
I brought my mom.
I brought that same lady and we sat,...
...that same one.
The same mom.
We sat at a table next to Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie,...
...which is like, the ultimate thing to bring your mom to.
Sure.
Because she never drinks and there was this giant bottle of Moet Champagne,...
...because they were sponsoring the event.
And so, she had a lot of champagne and she was talking to them about their kids,...
...which was really interesting and funny.
So, your mom was getting pretty loose at the time.
She was like, "Now, you guys must be so tired."
"You two."
And she was leaning over me to Angelina Jolie and I'm like,...
...and Angelina was like, "Yeah, you know, all these kids."
My mom was like, "No, how old is the old?"
"They grow up so fast, you're gonna... it flies, it flies."
And I was like, "Oh boy... Oh boy."